yola marilou très populaire sur
instagram public vedettariat yala
marilou réalisatrice artistes de toutes
sortes de m'arriver laquelle vous voulez
vraiment montrer ou plus que vous voyez
ci c'est l'intérieur d'une taille la
mienne la vôtre moi ça me dérange pas
d'être plusieurs mâles où je trouve
qu'avec les années
je pense que celle que je suis le plus
c'est la réalisatrice c'est celle qui
est derrière la caméra qui me permet
d'être moi même qui ai pas confrontés à
une image qu'on a envie que je sois télé
pas de dons par an mais l'image qu'on
m'a voulu me donner dans les médias
c'est celle de la jeunesse c'est celle
qui correspondent à l'image boblbee de
mon personnage de ram danse comme si les
gens m'ont connu pendant huit ans avec
ce personnage là et avait envie que je
reste de cette fleur qui pétillent à
l'écran qui les gens puissent capable
d'être celle là aussi sauf ou non plus
[Musique]
même si dans mon fin fond dans mon
quotidien est un peu moins sûr toujours
plus introverti plus intellectuelle je
suis vraiment tombé dans ce métier-là
pas par hasard parce que j'ai cherché
quand même à avoir des auditions puis a
travaillé dans le milieu mais je ne
savais pas au moment où j'allais
commencer puisque j'ai commencé ça assez
jeune les packs que ça l'aurait et cette
espèce de côté populaire l'a vu le
vedettariat d'être connue ce n'est pas
quelque chose que je recherchais à
l'époque maintenance ponia non mais ça
me fait plaisir j'ai appris à
apprivoiser cette ville vous avez 174
mille abonnés sur instagram plus de 200
milles sur facebook comment ça va et
puis quand il n'y avait pas de manuels
d'instruction ne comment gérer ça s'est
fait en petit à petit au début vraiment
je suis à mon poste est qu un style
grand jeu l'avait utilisé parce que
jamais les filtres est à grands textes
rythmés photo était plus belle qu'à un
moment donné j'ai une amie julie
perreault qui me dit marc louis saha
etupes des photos où elles sont
accessibles à tous via wi mal foutu le
maître privé pour ce nom moi j'utilise
est vraiment c'est comme vraiment comme
un fils de photos
j'ai commencé à apprendre le gmi les
paramètres métier personne qui m'a
enseigné ce lait découvert une marelle
ou sur votre site internet où vous avez
une citation de frederico fellini
l'or est dans l'infini détail êtes une
fan de frédéric louf absolument moi mon
père mon père mon parent et psychiatres
mais était vraiment un grand cinéphile
était passionné de cinéma c'est pourquoi
je pense que je fais ça maintenant et
mon père aurait aimé faire des films et
et et aux études de comme médecin était
allé rencontrer claude jutra qui était
médecin et cinéaste puis avait dit
comment je vais faire des films il y
avait regardé pour étudier en france
à l'époque je n'avais pas les moyens
pour ce tout ça pour dire que mon père a
toujours amené sa main dans ma maison le
cinéma on avait un bêta rapidement dans
la maison quand s'était inventé avec un
écran géant et une filmographie
l'incroyable son bêta dont trois films
par cassettes avec tous des films
d'antonioni fenini toutes les clés ni
mais plus que le cinéma italien est un
élément important pour mon père mais
aussi les classiques du cinéma donc j'ai
vu beaucoup de ces films là est en gêne
parce que mon père me bli ga voir c'est
finalement françois de quoi est-ce que
tu parles
qu'est-ce que ça t'oblige à fernando on
vous attrape en pleine campagne de
promotion pour le film la course des
tuques
vous avez vu tout jeune la guerre des
tuques la version originale est là
aujourd'hui de l'interné sophie que tu
es la fille portant dans la garde et ce
passage qui viennent devant marcus
officiellement j'ai vu la garder
jusqu'au cinéma puis mais mon père à
l'époque les cinémas étaient pas
mentionné la même façon qu'ils aient les
gens pouvaient même investir au cinéma
et mon père y avait donc investi départ
dans les contes pour tous puis dit ce
que j'en ai vu plusieurs à l'époque cela
dit est d'obliger vue elle a gardé ce
que quand j'étais jeune au cinéma et
après ce ciné cadeau à chaque année ça
passe et fait que j'allais rue revu
revue ça vraiment fait partie de mon
imaginaire d'enfant squid j10 en
terminant mariloup wolfe qu'est ce qu'on
vous souhaite pour 2010 en 2010 neuf va
sortir mon deuxième long métrage je
voulais donc j'espère que le film votre
chez
le public mais cette année 2009 est plus
une donnée plus ouverte je dirais si les
gens ont des projets pour être devant la
caméra
ça serait ça et qu'il oeuvrerait
peut-être mieux ma vie avec mes enfants
mal élevés
merci vous